in this video I'm going to cover what to
eat based on your body type now there's
some similarities and there's some
differences so I'm gonna go through each
one so you can kind of get it but
there's two ways of doing this number
one if you're pretty much sure that what
body type you have you can go right to
that eating plan and you're going to
customize what meals that you want based
on your body type but if you're a mixed
body type or you feel like you're
although the body types then the best
thing to do is start out with the dream
and body type why because I would say
80% of the people are adrenal and
because here's the thing let's say you
do the adrenal body type eating plan and
it doesn't feel good to you it doesn't
click with you because it should feel
right then just go right to another body
type eating plan so I would start with
the adrenal and then if you don't seem
to feel as good or are you not losing as
much weight go right to the liver okay
the ovary type and the thyroid are very
specific to you'll know you have that
body type it's actually very rare to
have a primary thyroid but if you're on
thyroid medication then you you should
probably just go right to that or the
ovary type is very very similar but
you're gonna have weight mainly mainly
in the lower part only like the hips and
the thighs and that type of thing
so I would start here and then go to
here if you're confused chances are
you're going to go right here you're
gonna do very very well okay so let's
talk about the adrenal body type the
basic categories of food that you should
focus on number one is higher amounts of
protein and I'm not talking about what's
recommended is high my high is actually
low if you look at what is recommended
by the food pyramid whatever I mean they
recommend like I think 125 grams of
protein which is way way too high
we recommend between three and six
ounces per meal okay of protein animal
protein now the reason why the adrenal
needs more protein is simply because
their body is breaking down more protein
in the muscles and collagen in the skin
everything's kind of falling apart so
you need to replace that if you don't
replace
that protein you're gonna feel a little
bit weaker okay so and I'm not saying
that you should by eating like just
because you're losing protein your hair
nail skin eyes doesn't mean that eating
that protein is going to work what we're
trying to do is fix the hormone part of
this so you can't a belies the hormones
all right and it metabolize the protein
so it can actually be utilized by the
body so I have found people do actually
a little bit better sometimes in the
liver by cutting down protein and then
eating more vegetables cleaning up the
liver else in their hair comes back and
those kinds of things but I mean we're
just talking about three six ounces per
meal of animal protein if you're
vegetarian then do spirulina try to find
some other protein some protein powder I
prefer you do actual like eggs fish
chicken things like that and make sure
it's organic or free-range if possible
so we got high protein and then we have
high fat and I'm not talking about deep
fried Twinkies I'm talking about nuts
avocados cheese plain yogurt organic
yogurt whole milk yogurt the reason why
we need a bit more fat is because those
hormones are made from cholesterol
interestingly so what we want to do is
we're just you have to realize too that
like nuts and avocados and vegetable
type fats don't have any cholesterol in
them just FYI and plus we're going to be
cleaning our liver at the same time so
you're not gonna have to worry about it
so the point is we need a little bit
more fat because typically an adrenal
case has blood sugar issues and if
they're if you don't have enough fat in
the diet you tend to crash and burn and
you don't feel like you're satisfied so
the most important time to have that
protein is in the early part of the day
not right before bed so like right after
breakfast or at breakfast that's what's
recommended okay we don't recommend the
cruciferous vegetables that would be
kale broccoli brussel sprouts except
kale is probably going to be okay for
you in that kale shake but we don't
necessarily recommend the other
cruciferous vegetables simply because
adrenal cases typically have bloating
with those vegetables they get bloated
if you're bloating and you're gas from
those or your stomach pain you should
not be consuming those vegetables
instead consume other types of
vegetables like romaine lettuce spinach
tomato carrot celery those types of
things and I'll give you a list in the
document below so we recommend seven
cups of vegetables why because somehow
we have to get the nutrition in your
body and most the vitamins are in the
vegetable okay so that's generally what
you do for the adrenal type those are
the most most important now the ovary is
similar in that you need high protein
higher fat but we prefer if you do more
dairy like kefir yogurt cheese but we
have to have it organic okay and you can
get that at all sorts of stores and it
says no our BST BST BTS BST yeah yeah
it's no rBST that's no hormones okay so
that's what you would want to pay
attention to on the label if you're
getting cheese so we want that now
typically those um there are certain
factors in the area that actually
support the ovary type and they usually
crave that so instead of ice cream cream
cheese cheesecake we're doing cheese
dairy kefir yogurt things like that
alright these types the ovary type needs
cruciferous why because cruciferous are
anti estrogenic they have those
properties that balance estrogen it's
very important to clean up that estrogen
because ovary type is producing too much
estrogen so we want to clean it out and
the Cal shake would be good but don't be
afraid to have broccoli brussel sprouts
cabbage things like that as well it's
very cancer protecting as well now this
type no soy but I don't recommend soy in
general but specifically this type you
should not be doing any soy and it's
interesting because you have soy protein
isolates you have the powders and the
health bars and the protein bars and the
health shakes and all the different pre
pad
there's food diets have the soy as their
protein very bad low quality and you can
actually create a tumor in it as a
fibroid
all right so ovary cases are estrogen
dominant so cruciferous will balance it
out so that's the ovary
now we have the liver liver lower
protein probably three ounces per meal
why because the worse off the liver the
less you can digest protein the liver is
the organ that helps to metabolize the
protein so if you take someone with a
bad liver and you give them a lot of
protein they're gonna have a lot of
digestive issues it's going to be very
hard on the liver in fact what destroys
the liver is large quantities of cooked
meat or cook fat or deep fried fat so
that's why you don't go low fat low
protein and when people get older they
can't digest as much red meat or other
proteins because the liver is getting
bad one indication that your health
unhealthy livers that you don't digest
red meat and you don't do well don't
tolerate fat but they really crave fat
so they can have some but you're going
to probably have to add what's called
some bile salts that's bile salts and
you can get them I have them it's called
gall bladder support formula but that
has bile salts to help you digest more
fats that works really good if you bloat
burp belch and the thing about the liver
is that has you have problems on the
right side because of livers on the
right side so you would really the more
fat that you consume the more you're
gonna have red shoulder pain or bloating
or even headaches most headaches are
liver or gallbladder problems now
cruciferous very very very important to
consume these vegetables because
cruciferous not only have the most
nutrition but they have what's called
phytonutrients what pack is about a
nutrients those are the plant-based
chemicals that have unique properties
that are fight against many other
diseases like cancer like macular
degeneration like prostate problems like
breast cancer like all sorts of other
diseases so the drug companies actually
have done massive research to try to
isolate those chemicals
within the food that we eat and then
then they can patent those things but
for example kale has over 600
carotenoids what's the carotenoid it's a
it's a phytonutrient that actually is a
has it's like kind of like all the
different colored pigments dark green
dark purple dark red orange yellow are
phytonutrients and you can call them
antioxidants but phytonutrients are
really the true name and they have a lot
of great properties to protect you and
keep you healthy iceberg lettuce doesn't
have any phytonutrients okay and the
reason why you need those those factors
is that the liver is 3 and 1/2 pounds so
it needs something raw or in that shake
to be able to clean and heal the liver
the liver it loves bitter vegetables and
that's why the cruciferous work very
well on that so you want to consume
those vegetables in large quantities 7
to 10 cups a day to actually heal the
liver there's some good news and bad
news the good news about the liver it's
the one of the only organs that can
completely regenerate 100% the bad news
it takes 3 years of healthy eating to
achieve a brand new liver so again this
is going to help you so it's going to
protect you I mean even in your skin
your face it has a lot of vitamin A
which is how helps the skin but if you
have a little bile salts you'll absorb
more of the vitamin fat side with
vitamins vitamin A and you're going to
be better like if you have dry skin and
you're taking all this kale you stew up
dry skin you're just lacking the bile to
absorb that fat soluble vitamin okay one
thing about the liver is that liver
cases don't do well on peanut butter and
nuts and that's that seems to aggravate
it so they get bloating or right
shoulder pain so just if you have that
you know cut those down then we have the
thyroid the thyroid body type is waking
all over and they just have a very slow
metabolism and they don't do well with
high quantities of protein so we're
going to want to go low protein 3 ounces
we want to go low-fat because they can't
digest that and then we want to go know
cruciferous simply because sometimes
cruciferous can deplete the iodine now
you can do cruciferous as long as you
add iodine or seek help in the
so you can add some sea kelp and seaweed
and as a like maybe put in your salad or
something and then then you can consume
the cruciferous because cruciferous does
deplete iodine okay so those are the
those are things with thyroid one thing
I want to bring up right here if these
are general rules of thumb it's not
written in stone and you want to think
with information you might modify this
by having a little bit of this and
depending on how you feel for example
let's say you do one of these diets and
you start getting bloating there's two
reasons for bloating number one you have
a gallbladder problem and you need bile
salts okay if you have burping belching
bloating or it could be those nuts that
you're consuming or peanut butter then
you need more bath salts or cut down the
nuts and seeds because the fats not
being digested or it could be the
cruciferous vegetables why because many
people especially people with digestive
problems and adrenal issues cannot
digest those heavy fibers from the from
the broccoli and they have stomach pain
and bloating if you have that you have
to cut those out right now it's really a
lack of a certain enzyme which is means
it's lacking a certain bacteria that you
don't have in your gut because the
adrenal is destroyed it so you can
slowly build it up but for right now
just avoid it now if you get tired on
any one of these programs you need more
protein so start increasing the protein
some people leave more than others
you can't put everyone on the same diet
so just keep increasing it until your
fatigue goes away I know in my book in
chapter 10 I am making some tweaks
because if you're in adrenal case and
you go on that eating plan it says don't
eat any protein but you're going to get
a little bit tired if you have an
adrenal case now if you have cravings
for sweets all that means is you didn't
consume enough quantity of vegetable so
really put attention on at least 7 to 10
cups of vegetables it's not hard to do
if you do a kale shake and a couple
thoughts but it's the most important
thing because that's how we're going to
heal your body but if you're low on
potassium because you're not having the
any vegetable you're gonna keep craving
carbs your carb cravings should go away
within a couple days by consuming enough
greens and then lastly the right
shoulder pain that is the liver issue
that means that you're consuming too
many nuts
or peanut butter or something something
like that because when people start
doing this program a lot of times they
start loading up with nuts and they feel
really bloated in the right shoulder
pain so that will give you some
guidelines but go through the program
pick your meal plans go ahead and start
today and I'll see you in the next video